that's what Sarah wagenknechtspartei bsw wants for the European election.
bsw fundamentally criticizes,
that
Disregarders presumed to be in the public pillory
be put and not only with
undignified deformities,
but also with
practical performance bans or job losses.
with 20 pages is the
Program compared to other parties
relatively short and concentrated
on topics such as social
Justice,
Migration or also foreign policy.
instead of upgrade is one of their motorcycles,
a fair distribution of prosperity
and the taxation of the super-rich.
and migration wants to regulate more strictly anyway
and the EU should not get more power.
what local,
regional or
national
is better and more democratically adjustable,
must not meet the EU's regulatory mania
Technocracy to be left to.
a strengthening of sovereignty
democratically elected national parliaments.
but under Basic Law we want to know,
like parties uh,
family,
Sex,
Gender,
LGBTQI Plus
regulate - and what do you find about it in their program?
nothing.
nothing to LGBTQI Plus,
not to gender,
not on women's policy,
not to equality and so on and so forth.
and more Europe election programs you can find in our
Playlist and likes to make the plus go away.